allez un peu légèreté on va parler de
sport à présent avec un sport un peu
particulier et ça s'appelle le chass tag
alors le Chaz le Chase tag avec votre
anglais légendaire le principe il est
pourtant simple Aurélien il s'agit du
jeu du chat et de la souris auquel je
suis sûr vous jouillez dans la cour de
récréation un tour de rôle des athlètes
ont une vingtaine de secondes pour
secourir après au milieu de nombreux
obstacles un jeu bien sûr mais aussi un
véritable sport que nous font découvrir
Roméo marm et Léa
Turquier
[Musique]
aujourd'hui TV tour teste pour vous le
Chase tag une sorte de jeu du chat
revisité qui se joue dans une arène
juste derrière moi on a rendez-vous avec
un coach de la salle upside à
saint-avtin qui va nous expliquer un
petit peu les règles allez je me change
et c'est
[Musique]
parti salut Raphaël comment tu vas salut
ça va super et toi donc tu es coach à la
salle upside de saint-avvertin est-ce
que tu peux nous expliquer un petit peu
où est-ce qu'on on se trouve là et là on
est juste devant un terrain de chas tag
donc en gros c'est le jeu du CHA de la
sourée dans une arrêne pas besoin
forcément d'être un athlète ou un
traceur donc un pratiquant du parcours
pour pouvoir en faire suffit d'avoir un
petit peu garder son nomme d'enfant on
va dire si tu arrives à rester dans
l'arène pendant 20 secondes sans te
faire toucher c'est là où tu peux
marquer un et ben écoute tu peux me
montrer un petit peu comment on joue
ouais c'est parti allez super ok gauche
drite
c'est ça
ok là on on a plein de possibilité de
passage chacun est libre de faire ce
qu'il veut en fait ouais tu te déplaces
comme tu veux dans la structure
par-dessous par-dessus au
traversir c'est un sport qui aé inventé
par les frères dev c'est de britanniqu
et c'est l'un d'eux qui a eu l'idée en
fait en jouant avec son fils au chat
dans son jardin sauf que pour déposer le
brevet il a fallu le raccrocher à un
sport déjà existant c'est pour ça qu'il
y a beaucoup de similitudes avec le
parcours mais c'est bien deux
disciplines totalement différentes une
fois que tu es en jeu il y a il y a
toute cette dimension purement un peu ça
reste un jeu le côté instinctif chasseur
chassé ça fait vivre des émotions de fou
tu as réussi à à rentrer dans la tête de
l'adversaire tu l'as fait penser que tu
allais faire ça et au dernier moment bam
c'est aussi ça qui fait la trait du jeu
c'est que c'est facile à comprendre bien
s et c'est facile à pour démarrer
[Musique]
bravo alors comme vous pouvez le voir
c'est un sport qui est quand même assez
de mond en physiquement moi je suis pas
du tout un professionnel mais c'était
quand même une très belle expérience si
vous voulez voir des vrais
professionnels en action chaque année
depuis 2016 il y a le World Chase tag
c'est la compétition qui fait référence
et cocorico il y a quelques années il y
a une équipe Franco Suisse qui a gagner
la
compétition